Marian Williamson tweeted uh Kyle
Griffin of NBC news said Elise aonic
will not commit to certifying the 2024
election Maran Williams said Mar Marian
Williamson said this is insane let's
break it down what did Alise stanic
actually say she
said if it's constitutional yes I'll
certify it which is quite literally a
commitment to certify the election yep
because if it wasn't then the purpose of
her job is to not certify it Marion
Williamson gets this fake story from
Kyle Griffin of NBC he's lying
misleading through a mission to trick
people like Maran Williamson who
believes it Maran Williamson is the I
suppose you'd call this the the the
ignorance of evil we we all here like
Maran because she's a nice person she's
a good moral person but she believes
wrong things and we believe that if we
actually just talked to her she'd
understand and she did when she came on
the show when we showed her the the
creepy books and everything she like
these things are wrong and we're like
because you're a good person we know you
are but but if she believes NBC she
lives in a world of
lies and so this is what we end up
dealing with in the culture War the left
is a whole bunch of really really dumb
people and so when it comes to trying to
solve our problems you have disgusting
evil people like Oliver Darcy like Kyle
Griffin and then you're like how do we
actually make the world a better place
when you have figurative or literal
demons lying to stupid people to trick
them into harming themselves well I mean
everything you hear on the mainstream
media from NBC is is fake and I think
people are starting to realize that
though Tim don't you think or or do you
think people are still kind of under
that brainwash I think I think a lot of
people are starting to wake up to it you
know and I think programs like this and
the shift in how we consume media is
helping change this podcasts are taking
over but this is this is the Big
Challenge we have right now there would
be no question of the 20124 election if
we didn't have NBC News and CNN and
MSNBC lying in about everything these
people are they're evil it's it's not a
question it's malicious evil you and I
were actually talking about this earlier
today at lunch it would basically be
like if a health inspector was asked
will you pass this restaurant they're
like I mean if healthy it's someone
comes to you and says will building
inspector will you commit to certifying
my building that I will build next
year like what do you no I have to check
to see built right if it's up to Cod
then yeah and then I report building
inspector will not commit to certifying
the building it's like well you didn't
build it yet he'd actually be really bad
at his job if he did commit to
certifying it before seeing it yep
that's where we're currently at
Democrats are shocked first at a fake
story yo NBC News is the most captured
institution in this in this in the in
the media apparatus you think worse than
CNN absolutely wow NBC in ABC Disney yes
no question yo the the NBC News team
like Ben Collins they they fabricate the
most egregious things imaginable as a
statement of fact they put out
fabricated narratives come at me bro
statement of fact they do it and I
believe they do it intentionally I'd
love to get Discovery on these guys and
it's remarkable they give these people
awards look Alise stonic was asked would
she certify the election yeah if it's
constitutional of
course yes she said yes
and what does NBC news report she will
not commit to certifying the election
that's a lie that's just fake they they
fabricated that and then Marion
Williamson believes it and she's running
for president and polling in some in in
in some of the latest polls at
133% it's amazing isn't it the same
Media company I mean the only reason I
would say ABC is you know you saw that
video where they were trying to bring up
Jeffrey Epstein years ago and they
killed that story but whe whether or not
I think NBC news as a whole
is like a fake news machine well you
know Fox News you know I think Tucker
Carlson ran into this like you think oh
this is a conservative Media company but
there's a lot of liberal people that
work in there that are just in Hollywood
that are in Show Business I mean like do
you trust any of the political biases of
any of these networks I mean I I really
don't like I don't even yeah I don't
think Fox News NC news is is is is is a
king of the castle man yeah because I
guess the biggest I mean look NBC news
they did this thing once where some
activists wrote a fake story about me
NBC news then cited it in an article
then a bunch of entertainment Outlets
quoted NBC News NBC news then removed
the citation creating a dead Loop of a
bunch of entertainment news
organizations citing each other with no
actual source for where the claim came
from the original thing it was like a
blog or something is that they decided
it was a Blog just something yeah it was
some guy's blog and then when I
contacted one of these entertainment out
saying hey this is a fake story I want a
correction they say take it up with
insert other Outlet because they're the
ones who are making the claim then I
went to that so Outlet one says talk to
outlet two I go to outlet two and they
go hey look we're sting Outlet three I
went to outlet three and goes hey look
we're sting Outlet one so if it was just
two outlets and one and they're claiming
each other I could point out you guys
are just citing each other with three
Outlets they said I don't know what NBC
is doing we're citing this website and
then I said yeah but that that website
sting NBC and they were like I don't
know anything about that take it up with
them you can't sue me for defamation
because it's already in the public
sphere and we believe that what's
reported by insert Outlet is correct so
none of them will take it down that's
NBC News these people are despicable
evil they know they're lying and they
love playing this game where they go
online and they go Trump supporters are
lying and then when you stare him in the
face and talk to him and say Here's the
actual proof and report that you lied
they smile and say good luck evil people
man I don't disagree and then I see that
on Wikipedia too where like the somebody
have some weird Wikipedia thing and
it'll be cited to some random blog
you're like how does that well this is
they call it uh it was XKCD comic called
it pyogenesis
where they say uh the example actually
let me let me pull up side of Genesis
it's really really great you you you'll
understand how uh we are in a very
serious uh check it out where citations
come from setto Genesis step one through
a convoluted process a user's brain
generates facts these are typed into
Wikipedia The Scroll lock key was
designed by Future Energy Secretary
Steven Chew in a college project
somebody makes something up a rushed
writer checks Wikipedia for a summary of
their subject US Energy Secretary Steven
Chu comma Nobel Prize winner and creator
of the ubiquitous scroll lock key
testified before Congress today
surprised readers check Wikipedia see
the claim and flag it for review a
passing editor finds the piece and adds
it as a citation Google is your friend
people now that other writers have a
real Source they repeat the fact the
simple version is it's not just about
Wikipedia someone will fabricate a story
in the corporate press on purpose
remember the big scandal has been a
bunch that one guy who worked for build
in Germany was just making a bunch of
things up and they caught him someone
will make up something
or a better example Kyle Griffin will
tweet at least aonic will not commit to
certifying the election that's a that's
a fake story that's map fabricated by
Kyle Griffin he he made that up someone
like Marion Williamson will see this and
say this is insane and then I don't know
uh insert CNN or any other news Outlet
will write a story saying Mary
Williamson slams elista phonic saying it
is insane that she refuses to certify
the election they will then say NBC News
reported Elisa phonic says she will not
certify the 2024 election MH something
that never happened then every other
corporate Outlet will just rewrite what
CNN wrote citing CNN if CNN figures out
the mistake and they get rid of it all
these news outlets will just insert a
different source and create another loop
of of fake news this happens in Academia
too I can't remember who coined this
term but they refer to it as is ideal
laundering yep yeah makes sense you just
literally say anything and then you get
some citations a couple people cite you
and then people cite them and and the
language is manipulative right so if I
said you know if you describe Sheamus as
you know a thought criminal and then I
said Sheamus who has been described in
the past as a thought criminal I am
correct you have described him as a
thought criminal but is he actually or
has he just been described that way and
it becomes this like Echo chamber of
like worsening criticism sh
who obviously is the worst ever but this
is the game they play because the
corporate press loves to add descriptors
to people for no reason that's right so
uh yeah they'll say like Donald Trump
comma who who like Julian Assange he'll
be in the news because uh he released a
document they'll say Julian Sange comma
accused rapist and blah exactly not
relevant to the story but but not true
either the issue is what'll happen is
how many people have accused Bill
Clinton of being a pedophile everybody I
mean Millions right so if you were to
report that in a story Bill Clinton
comma an accused pedophile comma is that
a false statement effect absolutely not
he's been accused by a lot of people of
being a pedophile and this is the this
is the game that the corporate press
plays well speaking of pedophile and I
wanted to uh you know you aside from a
little bit I do because you know a lot
of people want to give Donald Trump
credit for saying the fake news but the
first person to say fake news and Tim
I'll kind of end on this conspiracy my
favorite conspiracy of them all you ask
me what my top one is I believe Micha
Jackson was innocent only because he was
uh you know he was the first person to
say that the news is fake and then on
top of that he was investigated by the
FBI for 19 years and then Wade Robinson
and James safechuck the two guys that
made the documentary leaving Neverland
Wade Robinson actually testified on his
behalf twice in front of California's
top prosecutor and said that nothing
happened and then James safechuck said
that he was um you know sexually
assaulted inside the train station in
the year that he said it the uh
architect hadn't even drawn the plans so
my point is yeah there's a lot of weird
inconsistencies with the Michael Jackson
situation yo look at the he's the first
one to say fake news so it is it is very
obvious that the left is willing to lie
about anything if it advances their
goals thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 P.M
and become a member over at timcast.net